what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we actually
have quite a bit of spider-man no way
home news we have a cover of spider-man
on the very front of empire magazine and
on that front it says multiverse and old
villains so of course we have to talk
about that also we seemingly know the
run time for spider-man knowing home and
it has recently been revealed what the
conversation looked like when kevin
feige told sony that marvel studios
should produce the next spider-man movie
which of course was spider-man
homecoming so as you can see a ton to
talk about and break down today so if
you're new don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest spider-man
videos and so you can enter our giveaway
we're giving away a really really sweet
spider-man figurine all you got to do to
enter subscribe to my channel and
subscribe to cosmic culture we'll link
that in the pin comment and description
down below okay so first thing that we
have to talk about obviously is this
cover because it is absolutely insane
not only do we get a pic of spider-man's
new suit but there is also so much going
on in this cover if you look to the
right we can obviously see a tentacle of
doc ock if you look to the left we can
obviously see a pumpkin bomb from the
green goblin and notice how that pumpkin
bomb on the left actually has a little
bit of a crack in it due to reality or
its universe breaking obviously the
green goblin that we are getting is
heavily rumored to be willem dafoe's
green goblin it's pretty much all but
confirmed at this point in time so
obviously willem dafoe's green goblin
comes from a different universe in fact
as far as we know so far all of these
villains are going to be coming from the
sam raimi spider-man universe and the
amazing spider-man universe which is why
the entire background pretty much looks
like a broken universe or a broken
reality now in the top right we can
actually see some lightning and this is
probably for jamie foxx's electro since
he himself has pretty much confirmed
that he is indeed coming back in this
movie also if you take a look at the
bottom left that definitely looks like
sand for sandman now originally i
thought that yellow line going down at
the bottom was initially a lightning
bolt but now i don't really think that's
the case i actually think that this
could be a timeline it kind of looks
like a timeline that the ancient one
showed professor hulk in avengers in
game and since we are dealing with the
multiverse and different realities and
doctor strange is obviously one of the
main characters of this film this could
perhaps be something very similar it
also very much looks like some of the
magic that doctor strange uses when he
performs the spell to try and erase the
memory of peter parker from the world it
looks a lot like the rings that
surrounded doctor strange and peter
parker when he did that spell and if you
actually look right under where it says
spider-man no way home it says old foes
new suits no rules marvel's multiverse
madness begins and we can obviously see
the multiverse tees in this photo again
with the shattered reality in the
background and all of the villains
coming out from that reality and i love
how it puts old foes right there on the
cover and it shows the pumpkin bomb and
the doc ock tentacle putting it right
out there right in front for the entire
world to see now of course in the
trailer we finally saw dog och we did
not see willem dafoe's green goblin but
we did see the pumpkin bomb which is
shown here and we didn't really see the
other villains which is why the sand for
sandman and the lightning for elektro
aren't so prominent in this cover but
they are there now the other two
villains they kind of haven't really
revealed yet we believe one to be the
lizard from the amazing spider-man
universe and we believe the other to be
rhino also from the amazing spider-man
universe but they've actually kept a
pretty tight lid on this and the villain
that we saw in the spider-man noah home
trailer that comes up from behind on
peter parker is very hard to make out a
lot of people think that it could
actually be venom especially since these
villains are shrouded in so much mystery
at this point in time but that's
something we'll have to wait just a
little bit longer to find out now of
course obviously what most people will
initially notice about this is
spider-man's new suit and it looks
pretty dang good now remember spider-man
is going to actually get a couple of new
suits at the very least in spider-man no
way home we know he's going to get an
integrated suit but we also know he's
going to get some type of magical suit
as well that doctor strange gives him or
in chance or both i guess now they did
release another poster as well it's an
alternate poster for subscribers to
empire magazine it's definitely more of
an artistic cover it's definitely art
but what's interesting about this one is
that in the middle it shows spider-man's
face and it kind of shows a bunch of
other faces kind of going down into a
web now obviously what i want to say is
that this kind of stands for multiple
different spider-man i think most people
know that i obviously believe that toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man are going to be in the film
and i would love to say that this is
kind of hinting at that but i actually
just think it's kind of an artistic
photo and that's a really cool design
that they did but you never know and
this does kind of focus on the other
universal villains we can see the doc
ock tentacles we can see sandman's fist
actually coming out we can see a pumpkin
bomb and i can actually see the eye of
agamotto and it looks like it actually
has the time stone in it which is rather
interesting considering the fact that
doctor strange should not have a time
stone right now because it was destroyed
in avengers in game i think needless to
say things are about to get pretty crazy
and spider-man knowing home and this is
going to be the true start of the
multiverse breaking into madness i mean
they're advertising it right on the
front cover of empire magazine and i
love how it says old foes it seems like
we're just diving into it a little bit
more right now which hopefully means
with the release of this and the
advertisement of old villains we could
be getting the trailer relatively soon i
know insiders have said two to three
weeks and hopefully it's two weeks and
that's not much longer we have to wait
and since they released these covers
that's a pretty good sign and hopefully
the tease of old villains also means
that we could be getting the tease of
old spider-man in the next trailer so
hopefully we get all of that very very
soon now according to daniel richmond
and according to big screen leaks we
seemingly know what the run time of
spider-man no way home could possibly be
big screen leaks came out and tweeted
today and said the tentative run time
for spider-man no way home is 2 hours 32
minutes and 55 seconds but they did also
say this will probably change as it's
from an early cut of the film daniel rpk
then came out and said for real though
i'm hearing it's around 2 hours and 30
minutes so i'm assuming that that's kind
of what their goal is that's what sony
and marvel are aiming for a two and a
half hour movie which is fantastic news
because if you have a movie that's going
to have six villains the sinister six
and they're from other universes and
other spider-man from other universes
you're gonna need some time to explain
that plus you're still gonna want to
focus on tom holland spider-man and his
individual story because it is his
franchise it is his movie still and
obviously i could deal with a four-hour
spider-man movie i think fans would
really really like a really long movie
which is kind of what we're getting here
at 2 hours and 30 minutes now something
i want to briefly touch on because i
want to do an entire video about this
but it's really really cool it was
recently revealed what the conversation
between kevin feige and sony looked like
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios the true goat sat down with amy
pasquel a producer for spider-man noway
home and talked about what the future
was going to look like originally they
were going to make an amazing spider-man
3. we know that andrew garfield was
supposed to get another movie toby was
also supposed to get a spider-man 4 but
that's neither here nor there but kevin
feige basically shut that down and
basically brought tom holland spider-man
a new spider-man into the mcu now really
what this in turn did is cancel
spider-man 3 the amazing spider-man 3
that is which is really really
interesting but kevin feige clearly had
a plan that sony agreed with but
obviously feige had a better plan
because what they went with was feige's
plan a whole entire new spider-man tom
holland spider-man that exists in the
mcu and it worked it was the first
spider-man movie to make a billion
dollars but i think there's more to it
than that since they were going to use
andrew garfield spider-man for the
amazing spider-man 3 i think the idea of
having a spider-verse and having him
show up for a spider-verse film was
really really easy i think that was an
easy decision for both studios since
they wanted andrew back for an amazing
spider-man 3 but didn't get that why not
bring him in for the spider-verse film
to me this is definitely a little bit
more evidence that hints towards andrew
garfield being in the movie but as i've
mentioned i 100 believe he is going to
100 be in the film even though he says
he's not the werewolf but let me know
what you think about all of this the new
covers of empire magazine the run time
and the conversation between kevin feige
and sony making a new spider-man leave
all your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to subscribe and like
the video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof